hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast molecular testing for
hereditary familial prostate cancer and
for risk assessment and localized
disease presented by dr. Judd Mao the
James H Siemens professor of surgery in
the division of urologic surgery the
director of the Duke prostate Center at
the Duke Cancer Institute at Duke
University Medical Center I'm dr. Susie
Valdez of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone at this event that it is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use that ask a question box
and let us know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
hand corner of your presentation window
and follow the process for obtaining
those credits without further ado please
join me in welcoming our presenter today
dr. Jed mal I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
it's a sincere pleasure to be with you
this afternoon and I want to thank lab
rubes for inviting me to prevent this
present this continuing medical
education program we're going to be
talking about prostate cancer and the
hot topic of hereditary and molecular
testing my disclosures I have been a
speaker in the past for myriad genetics
genomic health
and genome DX so one of the fundamental
questions all of us who take care of
patients with cancer and those of us who
do research in cancer what causes cancer
and certainly we see this group of men
sitting outside for guys older guys they
would be a typical clinic of mind and
men with prostate cancer or men with
enlarged prostate and what makes three
of those guys be okay and one of those
men develop prostate cancer certainly we
know about environmental factors you see
the picture here oh that someone's
smoking
fortunately smoking is not one of the
major risk for prostate cancer but
certainly other environmental factors
such as diet could be a risk factor for
prostate cancer and then you see a
cartoon here of DNA and the other key
issue is how much of cancer is related
to genetics so genetics are a major
cause of cancer as you see in this
headline genomic testing issues in the
era of precision medicine meaning we're
moving towards more individualized care
of patients with all types of cancer and
certainly this is the case in prostate
cancer as well and another headline
personalized genomic based care could
mean a paradigm shift that we've been
treating most of our patients based on
just stage and grade alone and we're
moving into an era where individual
genetics of tumors are going to direct
cancer care and that's going to be the
case with all cancers including prostate
cancer let's talk a little bit about the
basics we see here cement somatic versus
germline mutations so somatic mutations
are gene mutations or alterations that
are present in the tumor itself they
would be tested using tumor tissue and
looking for genetic alterations compare
that to germline mutation where a
mutation occurs in the DNA that's in
Hara
and we'll talk about that a little bit
further and that would form the basis
for development of hereditary cancer so
all cancer is genetic but not all cancer
is hereditary so that's an important
distinction and if we go back to our
basic biology we all have two copies of
normal genes on our two sets of
chromosomes and classically when we
think about genetics and cancer one
would have one damaging gene and one
normal gene and the patient's okay but
then when two damaged genes occur a
tumor develops in hereditary cancer one
of the damaged genes is inherited
therefore it takes less effort or less
random events to cause that second
damage and then a tumor develops so if
again if you're born with one altered
gene instead of having two mutations
developing two alleles you only need one
and this is why these hereditary
mutations or these inherited genetic
defects lead to a higher risk of cancer
and if we evaluate a hereditary cancer
risk and this is not just for prostate
cancer but pretty much all the cancers
we deal with most of the time with
regard to cancer it's sporadic meaning
we cannot identify a family history we
can't identify a family that's prone to
cancer on the other hand there are
patients who report a family history of
cancer and that may or may not increase
their risk of cancer and may or may not
increase the risk of harboring a
hereditary mutation that leads to
increased cancer and then we have the
true hereditary cancer in certain
ancestry such as the Astana C Jewish
ancestry may be an increased risk of
harboring hereditary cancer risk
who are these poor people
that were concerned about hereditary
cancer well think of multiple cancers in
a family cancers that occur in multi
multiple family members at a young age
and rare cancers so when we're now being
taught to take a better family history
we need to think about those factors and
at least take that history and a red
flag should go up in our minds when
we're dealing with patients who may have
multiple family members with cancer
particularly multiple young family
members with cancer or unusual cancers
now at the bottom of this slide there's
a quote here primarily targeted to
gynecologist telling them telling them
that they need to take these good family
histories to identify familial cancers
why is it and this was data in 2015 well
as we know breast cancer is not it
commonly has bracha mutations and so
that's been the hallmark disease and
we'll talk about that in a minute
but now we're talking about this among
urologist because we're identifying prom
or prostate cancers that are thought to
be due to hereditary cancer so let's
step back a little bit and compare tumor
testing versus germline testing so tumor
testing is basically when you take a
piece of a can't a tumor or a cancer and
you're looking for genetic alterations
or mutations in the tumor itself and
later on in the presentation we're going
to be talking about a number of
commercially available molecular genetic
tests that can be done on tumor tissue
so that's the second half of this talk
but before we get to that we're also
going to be talking about germline
testing that's basically testing the
blood and the saliva looking at our
heredity our constitutional DNA or what
we're born with with regard to our DNA
in all cells and trying to determine if
we inherited a mutation in one of these
cancer prone genes so again the testing
is
done on blood or saliva if you're
looking at germ line testing or tumor
tissue if you're testing some at for
somatic mutations the classic hereditary
cancer gene is the bracha family bracha
one and Brockett two and this is a
classic autosomal dominant hereditary
gene and I'll talk about a little bit
more in a minute but the baraka family
are in that what they call the DNA
repair family so these bracha one in
bracha to encode for proteins that help
our body cells repair itself from DNA
damage so you can understand if this
gene is mutated causing a messed up
baraka protein that then doesn't repair
a patient's a person's DNA properly it's
going to lead to an excess risk for
cancer and Sbrocco one and Branka to the
classic is hereditary breast and ovarian
cancer and this also leads to increased
risk of male breast cancer but the core
cancer risk meaning what are the most
common cancers that form in people and
who inherit abraca mutation and it would
be breast ovarian pancreatic prostate
and melanoma so those five cancers are
more commonly found in people who have
abraca 1 or 2 mutation again it's an
autosomal dominant inheritance and the
prevalence in the population is
estimated to be one in 300 to one and
500 so it's it's not that rare and this
just shows cancer risk associated with
bracha 1 and Brockett 2 mutations so you
see right here on the far left-hand side
of the slide female breast cancer
general population 7.3 but if a patient
of female inherits abraca 1 or 2
mutation her risk of breast cancer is
close to 90% it's
very high now I boxed here prostate
cancer in male breast cancer the
diseases that that I might see as a
urologist particularly prostate cancer
and it's not as pronounced as with
breast cancer but in the general
population lifetime risk of prostate
cancer is 8.2 that goes up to a 20% risk
with with abraca mutation so basically
looking at it another way about 20 you
know there's a much higher risk of a
patient who inherits a Bracken 1 or 2
mutation to develop prostate cancer over
their lifetime and similar with male
breast cancer and this just shows a
cartoon showing bracha 1 and bracket 2
proteins in this DNA repair pathway so
in all of our cells we have this
machinery this complex that if I mean
our bodies are undergoing DNA damage all
the time and are exposed to DNA damage
but most of the time this mechanism
repairs that DNA damage and prevents us
from going on to develop cancers due to
DNA damage however if bracket 1 bracket
2 or some of these other genes like ATM
check one check two ATR etc if these are
mutated or if a patient inherits a
mutation that messes these proteins up
then this machinery doesn't work
properly the DNA damage gets through and
increases the risk of cancer so that's
why patients who inherit these DNA
repair gene alteration you know who
inherits something that messes up this
repair mechanism are at increased risk
for cancer and so you know as a
urologist you know we see a lot of
patients a lot of males who have
elevated PSA and large prostate kidney
stones and all kinds of diseases of the
male urinary tract but to put this in
perspective in a large community or
ology practice who for example may be
diagnosing a thousand new prostate
cancer cases
per year anywhere from fifty to a
hundred and fifteen patients and that
practice could Harbor a mutation in one
of these genes if you say that practice
is caring for five thousand prostate
cancer survivors collectively there's
anywhere from two hundred and thirty to
five hundred ninety patients in that
Pratt in that single practice that may
have hereditary cancer gene mutation and
then if you just look at advanced
prostate cancer where these gene
mutations these hereditary cancer
mutations may be more common in a
practice who has 250 patients with
advanced prostate cancer 25 to 60
patients or more could have this
mutation so it's not rare it's something
that we need to think about and
potentially do better testing for now
the NCCN guidelines circa 2017 addressed
this a little bit they basically say
that in for prostate cancer we should
take a good family history and in this
box it talks about trying to identify a
patient's who may have a brother or
father or multiple family members
diagnosed with prostate cancer at age
less than 60 years of age those patients
might have a germline DNA repair gene
abnormality especially barakatu mutation
or they could have Lynch syndrome which
would be germline mutations in some of
the mismatch repair genes
so the key teaching point is trying to
teach us as urologist or as clinicians
who care for men with prostate cancer or
paint doctors who see men with elevated
PSA levels to take this better family
history and at least be thinking about
the possibility of aret eteri cancer
syndromes in the current guidelines that
include genetic testing are the NCCN
high-risk breast and ovarian guidelines
which does make prostate cancers
grading recommendations based on Branca
mutation stat status for example if we
identify if they identify a family who
has Branca mutations the male's who have
who may have a Branca mutation should
start prostate cancer screening at age
45
last year was 40 but I think the key
teaching point is that in Baraka
families or in families who have these
mutations they are an increased risk for
the male's developing prostate cancer
and those men need to be placed on some
type of focused testing program for
prostate cancer population screening for
prostate cancer in the general
population remains controversial but I
think there's less controversy
surrounding cancer prone families and
focused screening in those individuals
and this just shows again the 2017
Branka related breast and ovarian cancer
syndrome guidelines as I mentioned
earlier so let's just present an
illustrative case this is Damon David is
a sixty year old man who was diagnosed
with Gleason three plus four equals
seven prostate cancer he had a PSA of
four point eight no family history of
prostate cancer and he was placed on
active surveillance now for those on the
line who are who are joining us today
who do not do prostate cancer every day
this just is a typical patient we would
see he has middle grade prostate cancer
low volume disease fairly low PSA level
and active surveillance which simply
means that we're monitoring the cancer
closely and not intervening immediately
with surgery or radiation this active
surveillance is really gaining in
popularity around the United States and
around the world and so you see on this
this is David here in yellow so two
years later
David's PSA has risen to nine point five
he undergoes bone scan and cat scan just
to make sure there's no metastasis these
are all negative and so he switches from
active surveillance to undergoing a
radical prostatectomy and unfortunately
has positive pelvic lymph nodes which is
pretty uncommon but he has positive
nodes and he is placed on androgen
deprivation therapy his Gleason score in
the radical prostatectomy he was
upgraded to Gleason aid which is
considered high-grade cancer after the
surgery his PSA drops to zero indicating
that he is currently at this point
disease-free but four years later his
PSA remains zero but he's developed low
back pain and his bone scan was
suggestive of metastatic disease
interestingly a physical exam shows a
right breast mass which ends up being
biopsy proven invasive ductal carcinoma
so this gentleman had prostate cancer
and now has male breast cancer so there
should be a red flag that goes up he so
he has a mastectomy spine radiation
tamoxifen but a red flag didn't
necessarily go up at this point in time
until David's sister was diagnosed with
breast cancer
well the breast surgeons and the and/or
the gynecologist were all more on the
ball at that point in time at least then
the urologist or the doctors who were
caring for David with prostate cancer so
they recommend hereditary cancer testing
and lo and behold David's sister has a
mutation in bracket two and then they go
back and get a better family history
turns out that there's in the generation
prior to David and his sister the mother
had breast cancer at age 44 another
sister and had melanoma at 45 and if we
go back yet another generation there was
a grandfather who died
who died at age 62 of pancreatic cancer
so there's actually a fairly robust
family history here so Dave it
unfortunately was not tested had David
been tested for barakatu it would have
been positive and we would have found
out that David was not a good candidate
for active surveillance meaning he would
have had this bracket mutation detected
and we know now that patients with
prostate cancer who have abraca mutation
may have more serious cancer he would
have it would have been contraindicated
to place him on active surveillance and
so you know we see this headline
inherited mutation increase risk for
lethal prostate cancer and that's
referring to this study from Castro at
Al this was published in jco in 2013 and
the key teaching point is that patients
with hereditary bracken mutations
especially barakatu who present with
prostate cancer have more aggressive
more risk of advanced disease and that's
further illustrated on this slide well
actually let me go back for a minute
that's illustrated on this slide showing
that the disease-free survival overall
survival localized disease probability
is less in patients who have a bracha
mutation compared to controls so
patients who were non carriers versus
bracken mutation carriers the patients
with Braca mutations have a worse
prognosis so again the key teaching
point active surveillance would have
been totally irresponsible for this
patient with a bracken mutation but at
that time again this was a couple years
ago the medical community was not keyed
in on this this is all new information
over the last year or two so it's hard
to beat up on the doctors from a couple
years ago because they didn't know but
again now we would really want to take a
good family history and try to ascertain
that family
history before we put this gentleman on
active surveillance this slide just
talks about the fact that a lapper rib
one of the PARP inhibitors oral therapy
is used to treat patients who have
Branka 1 and bracket mini to bracket
mutations so whereas PARP inhibitors
would not be useful in the general
prostate cancer population patients
without these mutations specifically in
prostate cancer patients or patients
with other cancers where there is a
Branka mutation studies multiple studies
now have determined that the PARP
inhibitors are a very effective therapy
and I just wanted to make sure I put
that slide in here now because these
PARP inhibitors are starting to come
into play and prostate cancer in both
the situation where a patient would have
a germline Braca mutation but also in
tumor testing wear a bra commute ation
may be present somatically indicating
that that individual tumor had mutated
and had a Bracken mutation so back to
Damon and the summary in the key points
if David were to present with his
prostate cancer today he would clearly
meet criteria for genetic testing and
his barakatu mutation could be factored
into management one act of surveillance
would have been ill-advised or
contraindicated to his elevated risk for
breast cancer would be known and he
would he would have been under closer
surveillance likely allowing him to be
diagnosed at an earlier stage and 3 the
other brackets who carriers and the
family would likely have been identified
and his sister and daughter would have
would have options for avoiding breast
and other cancers so this is a real case
where the patient had a pretty strong
family history but it wasn't known by
them health care providers when they
treated David now let me switch gear
and talk specifically about patients who
present with metastatic prostate cancer
in other words this would be a patient
who for the when he first came to
attention with prostate cancer it had
already been metastatic this is not
necessarily the guy who you know had
early stage disease followed followed
followed and then later develop
metastatic prostate cancer this is for
the guy who presents de novo with
metastatic prostate cancer to the
emergency room the clinic or the
hospital and this is a paper from
Pritchard & Associates from the New
England Journal of Medicine from 2016
which i think is a real hallmark paper a
real classic because this paper shows
that about 12% of patients who present
with newly diagnosed metastatic prostate
cancer have a DNA repair gene mutation a
hereditary cancer mutation so this was
striking in that 12 percent of men with
metastatic prostate cancer actually have
hereditary prostate cancer pretty
amazing and almost half of these were
bracket bracket two mutations again if
you look at the overall group of about
12 percent of this 12 percent again 44
percent of the time it was a bracket
mutation bracket - thirteen percent of
the time it was an ATM twelve percent it
was checked - and then a smaller percent
bracket one now again all of these genes
are in this DNA repair pathway these are
all cases where that DNA repair
machinery was messed up because the
patient's inherited a mutation that
caused a disruption in protein function
of one of those genes and that in that
repair cascade now this is a slide that
shows a picture of a consensus panel
that was held
in March of 2017 about a year ago at my
alma mater Jefferson Medical College in
Philadelphia and I was blessed to be
part of this panel and this was
specifically convened to try to form the
basis for what urologist medical
oncologist and radiation oncologist
should do with regard to hereditary
cancer testing in specific setting of
prostate cancer or prostate disease and
the outcome of this consensus was
published just in the last month or two
in Journal of Clinical Oncology so for
those who are on this program today you
can go to JCO
early 2018 and the paper that was
published outlining the findings of this
panel so what is our status at Duke
University where I work well we are
doing germline testing in nearly all men
with metastatic prostate cancer there
are multiple commercial assays available
and I'm not here to endorse one over the
other but right now we're primarily
using the on v-j test which is a 44 gene
saliva or spit test or so in some cases
using the color test many insurance now
cover this test and given the recent NCN
the NCCN guidelines updates if positive
we refer to the head of hereditary
cancer clinic and we have kits in the
clinic and our nurses are trained to do
this in about ten minutes now let's
switch gears and spend the remaining
time we have talking about somatic
mutations and remember a somatic
mutation is a mutation in a gene that
occurs in the tissue not in the germ
line but in tissue such as the tumor
tissue of a patient who has cancer again
we talked about germline mutations
earlier and we know again
with looking at these somatic mutations
about 3/4 of men with localized prostate
cancer Harbor at least one mutation if
you interrogate their tumor again this
is looking at their tumor tissue and
looking for various molecular
alterations in this particular study of
over 300 samples 19% of the time it was
DNA repair genes 25% of time it was in
the wrasse or Pik Pik pathway but again
overall about three-quarters of the
patients had some molecular alteration
in metastatic castrate-resistant
prostate cancer it was even higher now
for those again on the on the program
today who do not do metastatic prostate
cancer or do prostate cancer work
primarily metastatic castrate-resistant
prostate cancer is the most far advanced
stage of prostate cancer and that is the
stage that again is the most advanced
many times those patients have multiple
areas of metastasis and those cancers
are progressing
despite prior hormonal therapy but in
this case a lot of the time you can find
clinically actionable genetic mutations
and theoretically in the future these
mutations could be targeted to come up
with novel therapeutics and even more
exciting and cool is the idea of being
able to measure these molecular
alterations in circulating tumor cells
and the technology has been getting
better and better and this is being
being used in other cancers aside from
prostate cancer but this headline just
goes to show that this technology is
advancing and theoretically one day all
patients with castrate resistant or
advanced prostate cancer may be able to
have their tumor tissue interrogated
looking at circulating tumor cells we're
not quite there yet but that's where
the field is is moving and this headline
new prostate cancer subtypes may predict
progression-free survival in other words
the idea of the future would be to do
that novel testing of circulating tumor
cells or of tumor tissue and to base
therapeutics more on the molecular
aspects than classic traditional aspects
of cancer stage and grade so in the last
group of slides I'm just going to talk
about some of the commercially available
molecular genetic tests that can be done
on tumor tissue and a prostate cancer
tumor tissue and we're going to break
that down into commercial molecular
tests that are done on the prostate
biopsy tissue where a gentleman is
diagnosed with prostate cancer through
needle biopsy and the needle biopsy
cancer cells are tested using commercial
assays and they're two that we're gonna
focus on myriad Pro lares and the other
one is genomic health Oncotype GPS and
then we're gonna also at the end just
mention decipher or the by genome DX
which is interrogating radical
prostatectomy tissue and so what is the
status in my institution again genetic
testing at the Duke prostate center on
our Duke Cancer Institute well like many
major institutions we have a die we have
a committee a diagnostic Technology
Committee that is a multidisciplinary
committee that must approve all send out
molecular genetic tests again when we
say send out these are tests that are
commercially done in in standalone labs
that are not done in our own hospital
laboratory department so that's why we
call them send out tests and so myriad
Pro lares was approved back in December
of 2012 so we've had that's been around
now for about six years the Oncotype GPS
was approved in 2000
14 decipher post radical prostatectomy
was approved in 2015 so I'm going to
spend just a little bit of a few slides
on Polaris Oncotype and decipher before
I do that I just want to put in a caveat
or two you know temper our enthusiasm
enthusiasm about these molecular tests
what do the NCCN guidelines say well all
of these tests are included in the
guidelines with a couple of caveats
number one first no randomized clinical
trial has yet assess the clinical
utility of these tests so in other words
no prospective randomized trials have
truly tested these markers similar to
the way drugs are tested second no test
has been shown to be predictive of
prostate cancer specific outcomes in
response to various management
strategies for example even though we
use these tests to help make decisions
between active treatment and active
surveillance we don't have any good
prospective data with long-term outcomes
to know if for example if we did this
test patients live longer than patients
who didn't have the test that's going to
take a long time to get that data and
thirdly and finally there are no
head-to-head comparisons of these assays
particularly when you have to commercial
assays for example that can be done on
prostate biopsy tissue we're not sure
which is better so with that let's just
spend a little a couple of slides on pro
lares and Oncotype so myriad Pro laris
Genet generically is is referred to as
the CCP gene function test obviously the
commercial name is myriad Pro lares but
if we're referring to this generically
at CCP gene function test and the reason
its CCP cells stands for cell cycle
progression
so all the genes in this panel are in
the cell cycle progression pathway and
there are thirty thirty let's say 31
genes plus 15 housekeeping genes that
comprise the assay the Oncotype is based
on 17 genes these are spread out in
various cellular pathways and of the 17
genes 12 are active and 5 of these genes
are considered housekeeping genes if we
do a comparison
both of these commercially available
molecular genetic assays our RNA
expression panels so they're measuring
up regulation and down regulation of
these genes in comparison to the
housekeeping genes and the assays and
the up regulation and down great down
regulation pattern makes up a
proprietary score which measures the
aggressiveness or non aggressiveness of
the cancer and the both of these can be
done on prostate biopsy tissue the
myriad Pro lares in addition can be
commercially done on radical
prostatectomy tissue and the pro lares
can be ordered on all grades of cancer
whereas the Oncotype test is more
limited to newly diagnosed men with low
to intermediate risk prostate cancer
Gleason 6 or low volume Gleason 7 who
have had a biopsy within the past 12
months so on label use would be a little
bit more restrictive for the genomic
health test the limitations of both pro
lares and Oncotype is that neither have
been prospectively validated in an
active surveillance population in other
words the most common use for these
tests is to get a better grip on the
patient's individual tumor
aggressiveness and using that
information it can help the patient and
the doctor make a decision if the
patient should be monitored under active
surveillance or have immediate surgery
or radiation and so even though these
tests are used in that type of clinical
situation we really have not had a
prospective lis validated study
specifically in active surveillance with
long term follow-up to really know the
true benefit of these tests it is
unclear which of the two tests is better
the tests are fairly costly three 3,000
and 3,500 but they are covered by
Medicare and many private insurance
plans now cover these tests and then
also how the information is presented to
the patient is not standardized and
physician biases and patient Wis wishes
when variably affect treatment decisions
and they're not globally available so
with those caveats though these tests
are now fairly commonly used by
urologist with early stage prostate
cancer patients especially when they're
trying to make decisions between active
treatment and active surveillance the
final thing I'll mention is the decipher
test and the decipher test is done on
radical prostatectomy archival tissue
it's a multiplex gene tip chip
technology and it's a 22 gene genomic
classifier test so if you go to the
literature and you want to use the
generic term for decipher in the
literature this is referred to the
prostate genomic classifier test the
test is Medicare reimbursed it can be
ordered on Medicare patients up to four
years post radical prostatectomy and the
indication for the test is adverse
pathology meaning the patient on
surgical pathology would have positive
surgical margins or extra capsular
extension
or seminal vesicle invasion or you know
having adverse pathology now if the
patient has organ confined disease early
stage organ combined disease and does
not have any adverse pathology the test
is not indicated and not covered by
Medicare and so this cartoon just shows
where it's positioned this is a test
done after radical prostatectomy when
you have the surgical pathology specimen
and you send a representative sample of
that tissue to the decipher laboratory
in California and the idea is to use
this test for the patient and the doctor
to make better clinical decisions about
possible possible adjuvant therapy or
Salvage their therapy that might be
needed after the surgery to help provide
a better long-term cure rate this is the
sample report and it places patients
into a low-risk average risk or high
risk group post prostatectomy and
provides the patient's relative risk of
metastasis and and then compares that to
a control population and you see this
headline genomic testing predicts
radiotherapy benefit after prostatectomy
this is referring to a nice study that
was more recently published in Journal
of Clinical Oncology as you see here in
this title slide genomic classifier
identify then with adverse pathology
after a radical prostatectomy who
benefit from entry of asthma radiation
therapy and I'll just give you the
highlights of this article so decipher
high-risk patients who received adjuvant
radiation therapy had an 80% reduction
in metastasis risk compared to those who
received Salvage radiation whereas
decipher low-risk patients showed no
difference in the test is that five
years for sound Salvage or asthma let me
just step back for a little bit again
those people who are on the program to
who don't do prostate cancer regularly
in a guy who's had a radical
prostatectomy and has adverse pathology
some experts say you should just
automatically give that man radiation
Agilent Li meaning just automatically
just for the adversity ology other
experts say no wait don't give the
Agilent radiation only give that man
radiation if the PSA rises meaning if
the the blood marker rises to indicate
recurrent disease and that type of
radiation is called Salvage radiation so
the key teaching point was that by
clinicians using the deciphered test it
helped them make decisions between
whether they should pull the trigger for
early radiation or simply wait for the
PSA to rise and only pull the trigger
for radiation with PSA rise and so this
again this slide just shows that
decipher might help provide therapy to
those patients who are likely to benefit
but to spare other patients unnecessary
treatment so decipher low-risk patients
can be managed safely with observation
until their PSA rise in other words
they're okay to just go ahead and wait
and only do radiation if the PSA Rises
which is called Salvage radiotherapy but
to site for high-risk patients
experience lower rates of metastasis
when treated with adjuvant so if you get
a decipher high risk in a patient who
already has adverse pathology on their
radical prostatectomy this data suggests
that you should just go ahead and pull
the trigger for radiation early and not
wait for the PSA to rise so this is just
an example where a molecular marker test
was able to actually help make true
important clinical decisions in patients
now the caveat here is time will tell if
this pans out in the long run and and
the naysayers would say that well this
is all well and good but we still don't
know if patients who had decipher
ultimately live longer than patients who
didn't have decipher where the doctors
just based their decisions on other
on molecular aspects so again looks
promising but a true skeptic would say
well I'm gonna wait another decade
before I use these things because I want
to make I want to see if ultimately
decipher improves long-term survival
just like a drug therapy so that was my
my last slide is more of a summary and
then we're going to open up for
questions
I think the key teaching points from
this presentation is that we really need
to understand not just in prostate
cancer but on all cancers we deal with
the difference between germline versus
somatic DNA or molecular testing that's
a critical distinction we really need to
be mindful of hereditary cancers and
again since I'm a urologist working in
the prostate cancer space me and my
colleagues who deal with prostate cancer
we definitely need to be more mindful of
thinking about the possibility of
hereditary prostate cancer risk and we
talked about those risk factors earlier
we should consider germline DNA testing
selectively again based on the family
history based on a hunch that the
patient may have hereditary cancer
syndrome we talked about baraka one and
Branka two being the classic autosomal
dominant gene DNA repair genes and that
PARP inhibitors are clinically useful as
therapeutics in patients with various
cancer who Harbor bracha one and
Brockett two mutations then in the last
part of the talk we talked about the
commercially available molecular
biomarkers we talked about both myriad
Pro lares and genomic health on to type
GPS being molecular RNA based assays RNA
based expression profiles that use
biopsy tissue used archival prostate
biopsy tissue to interrogate messenger
RNA and these multi gene expression
channels and primarily these tests are
used to help doctors and patients make
decisions between whether the patients
should go inactive sustained active
surveillance or have active treatment
such as surgery or radiation therapy and
finally we talked about the genomic
classifier tests commercially known as
decipher which is uses a gene ship
analysis again expression panels of
various genes to help us make better
decisions
post radical prostatectomy between
observation or early radiation or later
radiation when the PSA rises so with
that again I really want to thank the
audience for sticking with me and we now
like to I know there have been questions
that have been coming in as I've been
giving the talk so we'll turn it over to
our moderator to address some of the
questions that have come in during our
presentation
thank you dr. Mao for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type those questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click the send
button we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's get started
and look at our incoming questions from
our audience members already our first
question dr. mal is for a typical man
presenting with costate cancer what
should doctors and health care providers
be looking for or asking that might
suggest the need for hereditary cancer
gene testing so that's a really good
question and that hits at the beginning
of the talk that again we just meet need
to be more mindful of thinking about
this having it in our mind when we take
a family history and we should be asking
patients about whether how many
generation you know if there's been
multiple generations with cancer the
different types of cans
that are present particularly in
brothers sisters parents aunts and
uncles and grandparents and we really
should be thinking about if the patient
has several family members with various
with cancers particularly if those
cancers developed in family members less
than sixty or a double red flag as if
those cancers developed at less than
fifty and again the ones that we really
are should raise a suspicion is breast
cancer in a young age ovarian cancer
pancreatic cancer melanoma colorectal
cancer and prostate cancer especially if
some of those are running together in a
family again we presented that the David
case and the fact that then we went back
generations and found that there were
young people in that family who had
breast cancer younger people and
pancreatic cancer young person with
melanoma all in his blood relatives that
was that Kay that his case is classic
for Branca mutations so again be mindful
of it think about it and and just have a
high index of suspicion Niki dr. mouth
and should all men who present the
metastatic prostate cancer be tested for
hereditary prostate cancer James again
another great question I think there
were there definitely people listening
in we really appreciate Don people's
attention on this program and obviously
someone was literally listening
listening intently on yeah let me make
that distinction so in when we have a
prostate cancer clinic or men with
prostate cancer we have some men who
present early some men who have been
compulsive about getting screened and
they get tests it picked up with early
stage disease and have no metastases and
those men say go on to surgery or
radiation or have active surveillance in
those men
who have localized prostate cancer the
risk of those men having hereditary
cancers is less than 5% it's about four
to five percent on the other hand if
it's a population of men who who just
present off the street with metastases
you know they show up in the emergency
room one day and have bone Mets and bone
pain or or they you know see the doctor
for some symptom and lo and behold
they're found out metastatic disease
right from the get-go those men have
about a twelve or thirteen percent
chance of having hereditary cancer so
the key teaching point is again if a guy
presents with men if you see a guy who's
de novo with metastatic disease never
had prostate cancer before bingo shows
up at your clinic and unfortunately has
advanced disease right from the start
that guy has a again twelve thirteen
percent chance of having hereditary
cancer you could you could argue that
all those men should be Tet or offered
testing but particularly if that man
with metastatic disease also has a
family history then it's obviously a
no-brainer as I said it Duke we tend to
offer that testing to anybody who
presents to our clinic with newly
diagnosed metastatic disease where it
was a you know first time presentation
with prostate cancer with Mets thank you
and what is the active surveillance for
prostate cancer yeah that's another good
point again I know folks listening in on
the program today or on our webcast you
know some of them are likely to be
people who are very familiar with
prostate cancer and there may be others
on the line who may be laboratory people
or people who are just casually aware of
prostate cancer but may not really keep
up with it what it is is that we've
learned over the last five years or so
that many men with early-stage prostate
as her particularly early-stage prostate
cancer and low-grade prostate cancer
with lower PSA levels may have an
indolent non aggressive form of prostate
cancer that does not require aggressive
treatment and these cancers can be
monitored over time without aggressive
treatment and that concept is called
active surveillance and in general these
patients are seen by their urologist or
oncologist every four to six months for
PSA testing prostate exams and perhaps
periodic repeat prostate biopsies or
prostate MRIs or other imaging
modalities and so we're actively
monitoring that cancer but we're not
immediately recommending surgery or
radiation or some aggressive treatment
thank you dr. mal and I do want to also
thank our audience members for their
great questions coming in and remind
them that any questions not answered
today will be answered via email who is
the ideal patient candidate for testing
their prostate cancer biopsy specimen
with commercial molecular marker tests
so well first off that's a great point
and I want to make this key teaching
point I really don't believe that we
should be doing reflex testing in any
case meaning we should never order a
test a doctor should never order a test
unless he has a good he or she has a
good reason meaning why order a test if
you're not going to use that information
to help you make a clinical decision so
first off and if we're focusing on
prostate cancer today you know if it's
clear to you and your patient what your
course of action is based on standard
information you know if you in other
words if you know based on PSA level
based on the regular prostate biopsy and
based on other
known clinical factors you know what the
patient wants to do you know what to do
it's not controversial I'm not sure you
need a molecular test just for the sake
of doing it but many men are confused
many men have kind of prostate cancer
that could go either way it's it's not
really good it's not really bad it's
kind of middle of the road they have
early stage disease you know they they
certainly will do surgery if they have
to butt surgery has collateral damage in
this in the point of having erectile
dysfunction or urinary incontinence so
they're not excited to have surgery or
radiation if they don't have to anyway
the point is is the best candidates in
currently in prostate cancer would be a
gentleman who has early-stage prostate
cancer and is trying to decide between
whether that can't whether he needs to
have that cancer immediately treated or
whether he can do active surveillance
and in that setting either the myriad
pro lares tests that we talked about or
the Oncotype GPS test can provide
additional information that can help
some doctors and some patients make
better decisions between active
treatment and active surveillance I
think that you answered partly this next
question which is which is the best
commercial molecular marker test for men
who are considering active surveillance
for localized prostate cancer so another
great question and the honest answer is
I don't know I've had clinical
experience with both myriad pro lares
and Oncotype GPS both of the commercial
tests in many cases provide me with
unique clinical and form a unique
information that in individual patients
can help me make better to treatment
decisions and can help my patient make
better decisions however I'm not sure
which is better
we have no head-to-head comparison
between pro lares and Oncotype and so
I honestly struggle I have both of the
tests available and I'm not clear which
is better I will say this that pearl
Eris has a little bit broader clinical
use meaning it's commercially available
to be done in any grade of cancer
whereas the genomic health test is a
little more focused that were it's only
commercially available for patients with
low grade and intermediate grade cancer
so there's some subtle differences there
in in approved on label use that you
know doctors who are on this program
today if they're interested and haven't
used these tests before the best thing
to do is contact the company
representatives for both companies and
just ask them to come in and present on
both of them thank you dr. mal we have
time for one more question are all men
who undergo a radical prostatectomy
eligible to have the decipher molecular
molecular test done on their surgical
specimen now
so the decipher is again the third
molecular test that we talked about and
decipher the company genome DX I might
add also has a biopsy classifier so
there is a commercially available
decipher test for both prostate biopsy
and for radical prostatectomy but for
the sake of time on this program today I
only covered the decipher radical
prostatectomy test and that's the only
one that I have a lot of clinical
experience with but in the setting of
decipher for radical prostatectomy
tissue it's only for patients who have
adverse pathology meaning that if a
patient has organ confined disease after
radical prostatectomy his risk of
recurrence is so low that you really do
not need a molecular classifier to help
you make clinical decisions because
you're going
to observe that patient regardless but
if the patient has adverse pathology
after surgery and you're trying to make
a better decision between observing that
patient or doing additional radiation
the decipher test can be very useful as
the jco article implied to help make
those treatment decisions post-op dr.
Mouw thank you again for your
presentation today and your important
research would you like to provide the
audience member with any closing remarks
before we close today well I just like
to again say how honored and delighted I
have been to give this presentation I'm
really enthusiastic about this area I
think that again this is a great
opportunity for doctors who work in the
prostate cancer space to become more
acquainted with Loretta Terry cancers I
think that these measuring these
hereditary and somatic mutations are
going to lead to better cancer
characterization and better treatments
in the future but again I just want to
thank lab roots and thank you as the
moderator for for doing such a great job
and again it's been an honor and
pleasure being here absolutely and thank
you again sir I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcasts possible before we go I want to
remind audience members that sent these
webcasts will be available for on-demand
viewing through July 2018 they'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know that this webcast will be
available for replay please share this
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye